kampala la capital de uganda vive la
previa de las elecciones con la
presencia de militares en las calles son
ellos los encargados de la seguridad en
el área metropolitana de la ciudad en
una antesala marcada por la decisión del
gobierno el martes de suspender las
redes sociales y los servicios de
mensajería instantánea es el reflejo de
un clima electoral tenso hay detención
de candidatos y prohibición de reuniones
en noviembre 54 personas murieron tras
la intervención de las fuerzas de
seguridad en una serie de protestas en
el país tras el arresto de un candidato
opositor los medios también han sufrido
un asedio por parte de las fuerzas del
orden una actitud que justificaba así el
responsable de la policía
no buscamos intimidar a los medios
buscamos proteger las vidas de ustedes
aunque haya peligro de ustedes insisten
en salir entonces si podemos mostrarnos
agresivos por su bien para hacerlos
comprender que no salgan uganda se
independizó del reino unido en 1962 y
desde 1986 yoweri museveni está en el
poder en esta ocasión
18,1 millones de votantes registrados
que eligen entre 11 candidatos
presidenciales y también votan a 353
parlamentarios su población es de más de
45 millones de personas con 1,4 millones
de refugiados dentro de sus fronteras
una de las tasas más altas del mundo la
agricultura representa una importante
parte de sus exportaciones y aunque el
banco mundial reconoce que el sector ha
ayudado a reducir la pobreza la pandemia
ha ralentizado el crecimiento de su
economía el país vive una decadente
situación de derechos humanos que
preocupa a las naciones unidas ya
organizaciones internacionales